sorgt direkt mal am anfang es geht um
den saturnmond titan der ist nämlich
spektakulär wie sich immer mehr heraus
stellt der saturnmond ist in vielerlei
hinsicht der erde sehr ähnlich und auch
deswegen halten viele außerirdisches
leben dort für äußerst wahrscheinlich
die nasa plant bis zum jahr 2025 eine
art rhone die dragon fly zum titan zu
starten um nach möglichen landeplätzen
auf dem saturnmond ausschau zu halten
jetzt haben amerikanische
wissenschaftlerin wissenschaftler eine
weitere faszinierende erkenntnisse über
den titanen gewonnen wie die chancen
also für außerirdisches leben auf dem
titan stehen ihr habt euch genau dieses
video in der whatsapp community von
pixum science fiction gewünscht also
bitteschön hier ist es herzlich
willkommen
der titan ist der größte der saturnmonde
und er gilt als der erdähnlichste
himmelskörper im sonnensystem er besitzt
eine atmosphäre einen wahren kern sehen
regen und wolken sowie canons sein
oberfläche ist so groß wie die
kontinente afrika europa und asien
zusammen viele infos zu titan haben wir
durch die esa-sonde ruhigen bekommen die
von der raumsonde cassini dorthin
gebracht wurde
auf den bildern waren unter anderem
erdähnliche berger aus eis zu sehen
schon länger ist also klar dass die
oberfläche des saturnmonds zu großen
teilen mit flüssigkeit bedeckt ist
wieder eine ähnlichkeit zur erde doch in
den gewässern des zitates ist kein
wasser zu finden sondern kalte
kohlenwasserstoffe konkret handelt es
sich um eins das aus gefrorenen etan und
metern besteht jetzt hat ein team der
amerikanischen cornell university noch
mehr erstaunliche fakten zu titan
gewinnen können und zwar aufgrund der
auswertung der letzten daten die die
mittlerweile verglühte cassini raumsonde
gesammelt hatte und das ergebnis das
lässt wirklich aufhorchen die drei
großen mehrere im fachjargon jahre
genannt gleichen sich einander aus heißt
also sie haben einen gemeinsamen
meeresspiegel vergleichbar mit den ozean
der erde dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher alexander hess die flüssigkeit
pegel der drei polaren mare
unterscheiden sich nicht mehr als acht
meter voneinander das spricht dafür dass
diese sehen miteinander verbunden sind
auf unserer erde sorgt ein kompliziertes
system aus flüssen dazu dass der
meeresspiegel aus
beglichen ist wie dieser ausgleich auf
dem titan geschieht ist noch nicht
geklärt unterirdische verbindung also
schluchten oder kanäle könnten dafür
verantwortlich seien eine entdeckung des
amerikanischen forschungsteams spricht
dafür dass der großteil der titanen
flüssigkeit unterhalb seiner oberfläche
fließt nur diejenigen vertiefungen die
oberhalb des pegels der gefüllten
nachbar seen liegen sind nicht mit
flüssigkeit gefüllt da zuerst legen sie
tiefer würden auch sie sich fühlen das
spricht dafür dass es unter der
oberfläche eine verbindung gibt und dass
in der tiefe flüssige kohlenwasserstoffe
zirkulieren und auch die seen des titels
bleiben weiter rätselhaft denn sowohl
die gefüllten als auch die trockenen
mulden weisen extrem steile ufer auf
teilweise ragen die uferkante bis zu 200
meter in die tiefe forschungsteams
weltweit können sich zudem nicht
erklären warum die seen von teilweise
hunderte meter hohen hülsten umgeben
sind
wie lassen sich diese seltsamen sehen
form geologisch erklären
eine vermutung ist dass bestimmte
einsturz phänomene diese formationen
produzierten auf der erde wird das cars
genannt gemeint sind dabei kalkstein
informationen bei denen wasser teile des
gesteins löst und so höhlensysteme formt
fest steht jedenfalls nicht all diese
neuen faszinierenden erkenntnisse lassen
sich mit gängigen geologischen prozessen
erklären doch je mehr wir über den
saturnmond erfahren umso
wahrscheinlicher wird es dass wir dort
demnächst leben finden können oder aber
selbst umsiedeln können schon 2015
vermutete ein forschungsteam dass
mikroben auf dem titan leben die sich
von dem gas acetylen ernähren und methan
ausscheiden und die nasa ist nicht
allein bei ihrem plan den titan in
zukunft auch für den menschen bewohnbar
zu machen
die wissenschaftlerin amanda hendrix aus
arizona hat ein ganzes buch darüber
geschrieben warum der titan eine bessere
option für eine langfristige menschliche
siedlung ist als der mars unter anderem
konzentriert sie sich dabei auf die
kosmische strahlung vor der der titanen
durch seine dichte atmosphäre einen
natürlichen schutz bietet wenn er als
erstes neues zum thema und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen an
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks
zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen
oder fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
raumsonde cassini schafft durch flug
zwischen saturn und seinen ringen
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran